the governor of a Russian border region
says local forces have shot down drones
as it battles Fighters Jets who have
crossed from Ukraine violence broke out
on Monday in Belgrade on the border with
Ukraine a self-described anti-kremlin
group has claimed responsibility Russia
accuses Ukraine of sabotage Keith has
denied involvement
well the Kremlin says the incursion near
Belgrade is an attempt by Ukraine to
divert attention from Russia's capture
of the eastern city of parkmut but keep
says its forces still control an area to
the southwest of bhagmut and it is
making gradual advances on Saturday
Russia announced it had taken the last
few blocks in the city center after
months of fighting let's get more on
this we can speak to Yulia chapovalova
who was a journalist in Moscow Yulia
what exactly is going on in the Belgard
region
so in Russia's Belgrade region the
ministry of Defense continues forcing
out the illegal armed formations as they
say a counter-terrorism operation
continues uh on Monday there were
reports about helicopters in the Skies
over the region uh the head of the
Belgrade region also said that residents
of the driver on District of that cannot
return to their homes but he will inform
the people using his social networks and
the heads of local governments will also
bring the information when the district
is safe for them to return according to
the governor an elderly woman died on
Monday during their evacuation there are
also several wounded civilians in The
Villages where these saboteurs entered
as well as civilian infrastructure was
damaged according to sources on Monday
the graverong district was fired from a
multiple launch rocket system from the
territory of Ukraine the so-called
Bulgari 22 facility a close military
Camp was also attacked as a result of
the shelling two Russian soldiers were
killed four more were injured and the
so-called Russian um
well basically that's that's what's
going on there now
so who could be behind the attacks
because Keith says it's not them
well that's correct uh the so-called
freedom of Russia Legion uh has taken
responsibility for that tax uh they're
considered a terrorist organization in
Russia and are suspected to be connected
with the Ukrainian Armed Forces they say
their goal is to free Russia and change
its political system those people also
claimed responsibility for that attack
in the Belgard region back in February
according to Dimitri Pescow the Kremlin
spokesperson the ministry of Defense the
FSB and the Border centers have reported
to Putin to Mr Putin about that tank uh
to break into the Belgard region and he
also said that work is underway to kick
away the Ukrainian saboteurs from
Russian territory and destroy the group
and he said that there are enough forces
and means for that and also Dimitri
bisco said that the purpose of the
Ukrainian sabotage in the Belgard region
is to divert attention from the Bachman
direction to minimize the political
effect of the loss of bahmoud by the
Ukrainian side okay thank you for that
Julia shopovolova there for us in Moscow